warten auf sie eher palmer in tübingen
wahnsinnig dringt auf die ergebnisse
dieser mittwochsrunde oder sagen sie
einfach ich mache was ich für richtig
halte
soweit wir das können tun wir das wir
haben jetzt schon die dritte woche in
der wir in tübingen in allen kitas und
allen schulen soweit präsenzunterricht
stattfindet schülerinnen und schüler
personal lehrerin zehn jahren testen mit
sehr guten resultaten wir haben die neue
generation der schnelltest jemand selbst
anwenden kann in den schulen und kitas
wir hatten jetzt so 10.000 test sie
haben mit lisa federle jemand die gute
kontakte zu einem hersteller hat und als
klar war dies sind zugelassen für den
fremd für die fremdnutzung habe ich
gesagt auf die genehmigung zum
nasebohren warten wir jetzt nicht weil
es geht nur noch um die frage ob man die
selber anwenden kann das kann man das
völlig problemlos kinderleicht
tatsächlich wie nase bohren wir haben
jetzt 10.000 test gemacht und deswegen
können wir sicher sagen da war keiner
positiv schulen und kitas haben die
pandemien thüringen nicht vorangetrieben
und ich würde genau das gleiche konzept
denn wir durften sofort für unsere
innenstadt anwenden
wir könnten teststationen aufbauen wir
könnten die leute dort testen lassen
personalausweis vorlegen
er kriegt man sie sind die nächsten
sechs stunden nicht infektiös mit sehr
großer sicherheit und jetzt gehen sie
ruhig ins museum gehen sie shoppen gehen
sie schlimm
sie werden niemand anstiegen für die
nächsten sechs stunden ist es in ordnung
und das würde uns erlauben die jetzt so
schmerzhaft vermissten und geschlossenen
bereiche kontrolliert zu öffnen ohne die
pandemie als bisher zu befeuern dafür
trete ich an und ich hoffe dass das nach
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz möglich
wird das baden württemberg diesen
vorschlag heute so gemacht noch mal ganz
kurz die luft anhalten diskutieren wir
hier karl lauterbach
was ist dagegen zu sagen dass regionen
die städte die gut dastehen und die sich
eben auch natürlich an die vorgaben
halten die
die berühmten regeln sind nach denen wir
uns richten es die lockerungen
ausprobieren
da gehört es nicht zu sagen in der tat
das ist ja vorgesehen also in den
konzepten die wir schon beschlossen
haben und es wird auch zukünftig sie
sollen noch haben die rostocker nichts
von ihrer geringen inzidenz noch hat
übrigen nichts von ja wohl eher geringen
in sillian in der vergangenheit gesehen
also wenn man so etwas macht also eine
stadt ist schon offen die andere stadt
ist nicht fernreisen die menschen in die
stadt die offen ist diejenigen die aus
der stadt kommen die noch nicht offen
ist die haben die vielen fälle
das heißt sie tragen die vielen fälle
dann in die stadt wo also schon geöffnet
ist ich habe da ein paar im prinzip
ich lade das virus dann ankommt nach
rostock da sind noch wenige infizierte
da gibt es noch also menschen und das
kommt dann aus den städten wo die
inzidenz sehr hoch ist und der rostocker
bürgermeister das letzte woche hier bei
uns er hat nicht nur für diesen qr code
und blogger entsprechend geworben
sondern sagte natürlich würde man
unbedingt auch die besucher der stadt
dafür mit diesen tests folgen
die frage war ja allgemein deshalb haben
wir das in der vergangenheit nicht
gemacht haben nicht also ob das dem
decks mit den tests möglich ist ich will
aber also da ein bisschen wasser in den
wein geben
zunächst einmal also man darf die
möglichkeiten dieser tests auch nicht
überschätzen
wenn man den test selbst macht und man
ist positiv dann wird auf der grundlage
von studien
wenn das also jemand selbst macht uns
auch einigermaßen gut kann wird in sechs
von zehn fällen die aus der ansteckung
und auch die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man
jemanden ansteckt erkannt aber in vier
von zehn fällen nicht und somit sind die
tests also nicht zu überschätzen muss
man vorsichtig sein wenn die jetzt haben
ja vollalarm der die idee und mein gott
wie so haben wir nicht darüber
nachgedacht wir testen jetzt jeden ins
restaurant gehen oder ins und da können
wir den ganzen lockt das super ford
ablassen
das wird nicht stattfinden wenn wir das
signal geben wir lockern
dann werden viele menschen zum einen die
tests durchführen zum zweiten viele
dieser test haben sich die qualität der
test der von herrn partner hier erwähnt
wurde das ist ein test ist auch schon
also gibt nicht für selbst sondern für
profis quasi dass ein profi test der
jetzt für sehr
tesco zu hoher qualität aber die tester
jetzt zugelassen werden sollten hoppla
hopp 3 aber da sind ja da hängen ja noch
30 nach dem anderen das sind die ersten
30 sollen sie 30 andere in der zulassung
von vielen dieser tests wissen wir
überhaupt nicht wie gut die sind und die
werden aber auch auf den markt bringen
mit denen wirklich guten test könnten
wir natürlich dieses angebot also wenn
wir das nutzen da können wir die
nachfrage überhaupt nicht bedienen das
heißt wir müssten erstmal vorberaten ich
bin für so eine strategie aber ich sehe
den fehler dass wir jetzt quasi
unvorbereitet überhaupt mit den test auf
den markt gehen ohne dass die richtig
vorher geprüft worden sind die
allermeisten kenne mich mit disco dass
die allermeisten dieser test also die
man nur hier also sagen wir bewerten
kann auf der grundlage was hat der
hersteller gesagt die haben wir nie in
einem labor geprüft die tests die man
einigermaßen bewerten kann das sind die
die auch für profis schon zugelassen
sind und die würden dann einfach zum
selbst testen genutzt
aber jetzt schnell die tests zuzulassen
dass und es kommt noch ein zweites
problem dazu auf die schnelle
wir haben auch das problem wenn wir
nicht sicherstellen dass die positiv
getesteten dass die danach auch den pcr
machen und dem gesundheitsamt gemeldet
werden dann können auch viele positiv
getestet nach hause gehen und denken
auch vielleicht ist der test nicht
richtig gewesen
oder ich taste mich morgen noch mal und
dann dann also haben wir nachher zero
kvitova keine tests mehr stattfinden
und das ist ja alles lösbare probleme
nicht immer nur bedingten vortragen
ich habe erst mal ein problem
vorgetragenen problem sind nicht nur
automat aber keine lösung denn vortrag
ja da bekomme ich ja sehr gerne dazu
aber ich habe jetzt mal vorgeschlagen
dass das schnell gegangen ist daher war
das bin ich dafür dass wir das alles
besser vorbereiten und ich haben ist der
gedanke verstanden und wir fragen nach
münchen
herr lesch wir wissen von südkorea das
schon vor elf monaten erfolgreiche
schnelltests eingesetzt wurden um
öffnungen zu ermöglichen wir wissen aus
anderen ländern dass man mit tests und
mit schnell
öffnungen ermöglichen kann sind wir
weltmeister in der bürokratie sind die
weltmeister im verunmöglichen
wir haben offenbar bisschen spät darüber
nachgedacht uns somit tests auch
auszurüsten dass wir sagen wir mal
schrittweise tatsächlich anfangen
könnten überhaupt mal zu überprüfen
inwieweit es funktionieren kann ich
glaube wir haben was wir dringend
brauchen ist deutlich mehr pragmatismus
pragmatismus ist etwas was ein ein
system eine gewisse widerstandskraft
verleiht weil unterschiedliche lösungen
möglich sind also oft was auf der einen
seite möglichst auf der anderen seite
nicht möglich also mono manische
lösungen lassen sich hier überhaupt
nicht durchführen
ich möchte nur noch mal daran erinnern
wir haben im herbst letzten jahres einen
riesigen fehler gemacht und haben zu
zeiten wo die infektionszahlen relativ
niedrig waren keinen lockdown gehabt wir
sind stattdessen mit voller wucht in die
zweite welle hinein gerast und haben
dann sogar eine lockerung gemacht wie
viel zu schwach gewesen ist wie wir ja
inzwischen wissen haben einige
ministerpräsidenten sich dann noch mal
entschuldigt haben ihre fehlerhafte
einschätzung bestätigt und wir müssen
jetzt glaube ich eine neue variante wir
können nicht einfach wieder sagen wir
fangen wir fangen überall an zu öffnen
sondern wir brauchen eine ziemlich
gestaffelte gestaffelte lösung die
lebensbedingungen in südkorea sind
anders als bei uns also wir sind ein
sehr komplexer relativ komplexe
gesellschaft mit bieber ja auch sehen
politisch sehr föderalen strukturen wo
ganz unterschiedliche interessen eine
rolle spielen in diesem jahr nicht
zuletzt die vielen landtagswahlen das
sollten wir nicht vergessen
wir werden also es wäre besser bei der
kobik behandlung wir hätten keine wahlen
in diesem jahr dann wäre glaube ich die
politische die politische klasse
deutlich ruhiger und es gebe wesentlich
weniger diskussionen darüber werden nun
der schnellste lockerer ist oder die
oder welche ministerpräsidentin am
schnellsten lockert da wird uns viel
erspart bleiben wenn wir das hätten und
jetzt aktuell glaube ich müssen wir
einfach zusehen dass wir uns gut
ausrüsten mit sehr sehr viel test
kapazitäten und zwar wie herr lauterbach
sagt eben mit denen die wirklich gut
funktionieren um dann ganz langsam aber
wirklich ganz ganz vorsichtig zu lockern
es wird wenn uns das britische die
britische mutation überrollt dann kann
es uns passieren dass wir eine tsunami
welle an
an erkrankung kriegen die wir die wir
dann wieder in mit einer mit einem
heftigen lockdown beantworten das wissen
wir nicht
und natürlich muss man und das haben sie
auch schon in ihrer antwort erwähnt man
muss auch sagen das was jetzt am
allermeisten helfen würde wären
natürlich volle kraft aufs impfen
und da ist natürlich aber offensichtlich
auch der fortschritt eine schnecke rund
18 millionen briten wurden bislang mit
bayern tech pfizer oder astrazeneca
geimpft das sind 26 prozent der
bevölkerung
bei uns sind es gerade mal gut
dreieinhalb millionen menschen das sind
vier prozent der deutschen und bei uns
hat speziell astrazeneca ein
image-problem von knapp 1,5 millionen
impfdosen konnten bislang nur 15 prozent
verimpft werden
herr lesch würden sie sich mit
astrazeneca impfen lassen aber
selbstverständlich haben
warum legt das wie blei in den regalen
jetzt scheint mir eine ziemlich
hysterische reaktion von öffentlichkeit
zu sein oder es ist nicht richtig
kommuniziert worden was eigentlich die
wirkliche wirkung von astrazeneca
betrifft
astrazeneca schützt vor schweren
verläufen wird auf jeden fall mildern
wird dazu führen dass viel weniger
erkrankte ins bett wenn sie denn dann
infiziert werden in die krankenhäuser
müssen also es ist auf jeden fall
grundsätzlich so besser geimpft zu sein
als nicht gm zu sein
ich würde mich natürlich sofort sind
erstens weniger im block ausrufezeichen
susanne schreiber astrazeneca haben wir
beschrieben 1,2 millionen impfdosen das
würde das risiko in diesem land
tatsächlich maximal minimieren im
vergleich zu allem was wir ansonsten tun
können was würden sie sagen wer ein
angebot nicht annimmt der hat pech
gehabt
ich würde schon sagen dass wir im moment
einen impf angebot ausschlägt muss ich
vermutlich erstmal wieder
hintenanstellen oder zumindest muss man
es dann schnell jemand anderem geben der
es nötig hat
ja also es gibt natürlich die freie
entscheidung und das ist auch gut so
aber wer das ablehnt
der kann dann eben auch hoffentlich mehr
auf seinem platz in der priorisierung
pochen
wie machen sie das in tübingen herr
palmer was machen sie mit den
liegengebliebenen impfdosen krieg dass
der bürgermeister
haha nein ich habe mich nicht mit
impfdosen übrig waren bedient ganz
sicher nicht wir versuchen eine
berechtigte zu finden wir haben mit
unter anderem einige erzieherinnen und
lehrer in dieser woche impfen können
nachdem das neu bei der berechtigungs
gruppe 2 hinzugekommen ist ich glaube
bei der fehler bei astrazeneca waren
anderer nehme ich ihnen nicht für die
über 65-jährigen zuzulassen wir sehen
mal wieder über vorsichtig gewesen
da sieht es ja das risiko und da könnten
wir sehr viele leben retten statt dessen
haben wir gesagt wir wissen nicht so
genau weil die daten nicht klar genug
sind
ob man die bei älteren einsetzen kann
daneben von wird die jüngeren
das ist ein schwerer strategischer
fehler der leben kostet und dann liegt
auch herr lauterbach fragen wir ihn
gleich vorher wollen wir von frau
oberbeck wissen sie haben astrazeneca
noch nicht am start für oberberg aber
der kommt nächste woche wie viel
hoffnung legen sie darauf dass die
menschen sonst schon mit astra zenica
und ihr war
erzieher und grundschullehrer jetzt
schon entschieden damit genau und die
müssen sich aber melden die müssen
kommen dass genau das hat überhaupt aber
die kvb und die organisation die müssen
kommen genau ich hoffe ganz ganz toll
dass ganz viele erzieher und pädagogen
sich am sonntag auch schon impfen lassen
weil ich auch mit großer sorge betrachte
das es eben dieses image problem von
astrazeneca gibt ich kann es nicht
wirklich nachvollziehen ich bin auch der
meinung es ist ein guter impfstoff die
nebenwirkungen über die berichtet wird
die kennen wir auch von biontech oder
moderner und es ist einfach wichtig dass
geimpft wird weil letztendlich kann man
durch impfungen genau ende am
in dem in der ganzen pandemie sehen
wirklich licht am ende des tunnels und
das testen ist ganz wichtig ich bin für
umfangreiche tests für testen so werden
wir noch mal eine sekunde kämpfen das
ist ganz verrückt heute meldet sich
wieder markus söder hoppla die
ministerpräsidenten und sagen weg mit
einer priorisierung wenn astrazeneca
verschmäht wird von denen die es jetzt
angeboten bekommen dann geben wir es am
besten den hausärzten und die für impfen
diejenigen die bei ihnen in den praxen
impfen dann an diejenigen die in den
praxen stehen natürlich nach dann eine
priorisierung die die hausärzte vor sie
würden sie sagen das ist okay das ist
sicherlich schwierig und kannst du sehr
viel unmut führen für mich ist trotzdem
in erster linie wichtig dass geimpft
wird und für mich ist es absolut
inakzeptabel dass im stoff nicht genutzt
wird so und dann sind wir bei der frage
frau schreiber ist gleich dran wir sind
bei der frage herr lauterbach
der erfolg von großbritannien ist
ausgerechnet mit einem impfstoff zu
verzeichnen den die deutschen verstehen
kann man gleichzeitig neidisch sein
das ist hier nicht angemessen
aber ist das nicht der einzige impfstoff
der die großen erfolge in dieser
entschuldigung es war nur der fragebögen
über die tatsächlich also ich stimme
hier sogar ein paar mal zu also es war
ein großer fehler dass wir den impfstoff
von aster nicht für die über 65-jährigen
zugelassen haben wir die datenlage hätte
das zugelassen und die europäische
zulassungsbehörde hat da ja den zu den
impfstoff dafür auch zugelassen für
wenig und wir haben das nicht gemacht
muss sich das wie folgt überlegenen
30-jährigen betrachter und 81 jährigen
dann ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
beide infiziert sind dass der 80er
gestimmt stirbt 600 mal so hoch bei b17
sogar 1000 mal so hoch dass er ist ja in
dem stoff nicht so stark gewesen wäre
wären natürlich bei diesem riesigen
risiko viel besser placiert gewesen
es zeigt sich jetzt aber dass dieser
impfstoff bei den 80 jährigen das zeigen
daten aus england sogar vorzüglich wirkt
und vermeidet in 80 senkt das risiko
überhaupt ins krankenhaus zu müssen
geschweige denn zu versterben um 80
prozent
somit wirkt der impfstoff bei den
älteren genauso gut wie dabei und tag im
stoff
das war ein riesenfehler dass wir den
impfstoff beschädigt haben das habe ich
uns sehr früh gesagt ich bin ja
ebenfalls bisher noch nicht zum einsatz
gekommen was mag sich ändern und was
paar sicherheitsprobleme gab aber lange
rede kurzer sinn wenn ich als ebenfalls
unterwegs bin würde ich auch selbst
geben für alle im feld so würde ich
natürlich den astra impfstoff nehmen ein
ganz klares signal zu geben das ist ein
unfassbar guter impfstoff und dass wir
den nicht so verwenden wir verwenden
müssten ist war bitter so und wenn jetzt
der gesundheitsminister sagt dass er
alle astra weniger geimpften eine nach
impfung mit anderen weg sie ihnen
ermöglichen würde
das erhöht natürlich das vertrauen ich
darf auch nicht also aus mehreren
gründen falsch also erstens also gibt es
das gefühl dass mit dem impfstoff was
nicht stimmen muss weil eine weitere
impfung wird notwendig dann denkt der
laie natürlich dann nämlich sofort in
besseren impfstoff und zum zweiten haben
wir dafür überhaupt keine daten aus und
die studie die das prüft ob das über die
bei jedem dieser impfstoff muss er gegen
die mutter nachgeben klären wir wissen
ja dass es also mutationen jetzt schon
gibt die auch nach deutschland kommen wo
wir die eben stoffe anpassen müssen das
gilt aber für jeden stoff und somit war
das ein falsches signal
nun da mich das nicht vergessen was hier
markus söder vorstellt dass wir jetzt
den impfstoff in den hausarztpraxen an
jeden geben den astra im stoff das halte
ich für falsch
werden wir die ersten drei risikogruppen
öffnen würden und eben von dort mit dem
asta impfstoff jeden unter 65 dann würde
der impfstoff genug weggenommen
dann würden nicht zu liegen bleiben wir
hätten aber dann trotzdem die auch von
der vom ethikrat geforderte
priorisierung der hochrisikogruppe es
macht jetzt keinen sinn zu sagen nur
weil der impfstoff jetzt nicht sofort
weggenommen ist dafür müssen wir
erwerben geht da jetzt ein junger
fußballer oder liga geht an leute die
party machen wollen das wäre eine
verschwendung des impfstoffes und werden
wir das für die drei gruppen öffnen dann
geht er eben stoff weg so viel heimweh
gar nicht dann wird er mehr genommen aus
wir haben so und dann muss man fast frau
schreiber jemand hat es so formuliert
muss man sie will man sich gar nicht
vorstellen wie es eigentlich wäre wenn
wir die gesamte packung astra weniger
bekommen hätten und jetzt vor dieser
situation stünden die wir in deutschland
haben
wie fatal ist ist das 1 2 mio
impfdosen einfach so rum liegen also ich
bin gar nicht sicher ob das wirklich so
das problem ist weil wenn ich mir das in
berlin anschauen also ich höre dass ein
großer sorge dass die rumliegen es gibt
aber sehr viele patienten also gerade
vor erkrankte in diesen ersten drei
gruppen die überhaupt gar keine chance
haben an astrazeneca zu kommen ja und da
ist ein problem also es ist ja gar nicht
dass dieser impfstoff so unbeliebt ist
sondern man kommt nach wie vor nicht an
ihn heran die wir sind schlecht auch im
organisieren ja also in berlin gibt es
für vor erkrankte oder auch für andere
der zweiten und dritten gruppen
polizisten sonst rankommen und lehrer
aber gibt es keine möglichkeit jetzt
schon geimpft zu werden man es lieber
den impfstoff dort in den zentren
rumliegen aber die patienten ja nicht
impft und das finde ich ganz fatal
also wir können auch die wir können auch
die priorisierung beibehalten wir müssen
es nur einfach durchziehen wenn jemand
das ablehnt wenn die erste gruppe nicht
mehr möchte dann muss man es der zweiten
hand anbieten aber das passiert im
moment nicht das denken völlig recht
gerade in der zweiten gruppe sind viele
die vorerkrankung hatte warten auf den
impfstoff wenn wir das fall geben dann
wird der impfstoff genommen und wenn wir
das jetzt freigegeben und das kriegen
andere gruppen entweder nicht in der
dritten priorisierung also unter der
dritten priorisierung gruppe dann ist es
einfach schwierig dann werden wir
einfach mehr tote einkaufen hier mehr
weil wir müssen einfach sehen wenn wir
mit einer impfung jemanden schützen der
ein geringeres risiko hat dann wird muss
bleibt jemand anderes ungeimpft der ein
höheres risiko hat und das wird
statistisch zwangsläufig dazu führen
dass wir mehr tote haben und das sieht
der ethikrat muss ich auch sagen sehr
kritisch und wir haben uns da ja das
sehr gut überlegt in dieser gemeinsamen
stellungnahme dass man eben wirklich
priorisieren möchte dass die schweren
verläufe und die todesfälle vermieden
werden sollen und das war eine
priorisierung von anfang an schon nicht
ganz so drin weil keiner der vor kranken
in der ersten gruppe war aber nun haben
wir sehen ja zweiter und bevor sie zum
zuge kommen sollen wenn man schon wieder
das umwerfen das sehe ich sehr sehr
kritisch da hoffe ich dass man nicht
davon abweicht und ich muss auch sagen
das ist insgesamt ein riesiges problem
darstellt angesichts der tatsache dass
das corona wir es ja nicht verschwinden
wird selbst wenn wir alle mal durch
geimpft sind wir werden uns in zukunft
in deutschland in europa intensiv damit
beschäftigen müssen wie können wir uns
immer wieder aufs neue immunisieren
gegen neue mutationen genau wie bei der
grippe
das heißt wir werden nochmal ganz ganz
neu und und viel intensiver darüber
nachdenken müssen dass wir genügend
impfdosen haben dass wir sie mit
über die hausarztpraxen wie jedes jahr
immer wieder neu verteilen dass wir die
im skeptiker irgendwie mit ins boot
holen und dergleichen mehr da ist das
was jetzt alles passiert an logistischen
und kommunikationsproblemen ist wirklich
katastrophal wenn ich mir überlege dass
wir das jedes jahr immer wieder hätten
diese unfähigkeit endlich diesen
impfstoff in der bevölkerung zu
verteilen
da bin ich wirklich schwer erschüttert
darüber muss ich sagen andere länder
macht das ikea ist also vermasseln wir
uns gerade unseren erfindung oder
forschungserfolg durch diese wirklich
diese grauenhafte organisation durch die
bürokratie
also manchmal denke ich wirklich es wäre
besser nicht darüber zu sprechen sondern
einfach zusehen dass mehr geimpft wird
dass man sozusagen öffentliche debatten
einfach unterlässt und nach dem motto
wie viel unheil ist durch nicht darüber
sprechen schon verhindert worden
um einfach die dinge in bewegung zu
bringen also manchmal habe ich das
gefühl dass nach einem solchen abend
dinge einfach nicht mehr nicht passieren
weil man hat zwar darüber gesprochen
aber es ist in der in der realität nicht
wirklich was passiert
das ist nicht besser geworden sondern
immer wieder wird gesprochen und es
werden immer wieder neue fehler gemacht
die mir im verlauf dieser dieser
pandemie jetzt eigentlich teilweise in
diesem jahr vor allen dingen sehr
rätselhaft geworden können sie denn
erklären woher diese zurückhaltung kommt
gibt es gründe zögerlich zu sein bei
astrazeneca und zu sagen das sind
adenoviren da kann es nebenwirkungen
geben die wir noch nicht richtig kennen
gibt es gründe bei anderen impfstoffen
zögerlich zu sein und zu sagen
neue prozesse neue impfstoffe da kennen
wir noch nicht wirklich alle
nebenwirkungen woher kommt das also wir
haben nun wirklich in etlichen sendungen
alles mögliche versucht und darzustellen
dass es diese gründe nicht gibt wir
haben alles mögliche versucht und es ist
mir es ist mir teilweise schleierhaft es
ist aber offenbar tatsächlich so dass
diese entwicklungen für viele leute
einfach rätselhaft sind wie kann das
sein dass wir jetzt praktisch unser spot
einen impfstoff haben wo das doch früher
über viele jahre gedauert hat wie kann
das sein dass wir jetzt irgendwelche
moleküle in uns impfen lassen die dann
und die werden irgendwie ist noch so
altes schulwissen da rna das ist doch
klingt so wie dr
wird da etwa jemand erbgut verändert wir
haben ja wirklich alle möglichen
aufklärungskampagnen in den
öffentlich-rechtlichen wirklich ganz
stark gemacht aber im grunde genommen in
der in der gesamten medialen welt ist es
immer wieder erklärt worden und trotzdem
kommen wir nicht durch weil offenbar
diese entwicklung für viele menschen so
unüberschaubar sind und so ungewiss dass
man nicht so richtig weiß ob das alles
stimmt auf der anderen seite muss man
doch mal ganz klar ganz klar sehen wir
haben eine riesenmenge von menschen die
auf der welt geimpft worden sind mit
diesen impfstoffen
wir sind also weit über diese klinischen
testphasen hinaus und wir sehen es
klappt wunderbar also ich kann nur alle
ermuntern lassen sie sich impfen das ist
gelebte solidarität das brauchen wir
ganz ganz druck herr palmer und dann
noch mal die frage auch an sie grüner
und ich sag's gern oder ungern
waldorfschüler wie sie verlegen sie ob
es nicht langzeitschäden geben kann
wie sehr haben sie darüber nachgedacht
sie sind proband bei cure weg ob es
nicht nebenwirkungen geben kann bei den
vektor impfstoff von astrazeneca wegen
der adenoviren also sie lesen da
sicherlich auch jedes papier
haben sie sorgen um nebenwirkungen
ich bin hier waldorfschüler ich bin nach
studierter mathematiker das gleicht sich
ganz gut aus denn ich kann risiken
einschätzen und es ist noch ganz
eindeutig so dass in meinem alter das
risiko der erkrankung durch des corona
virus um ein vielfaches größer ist als
das risiko der impfung das heißt nicht
dass es keine risiken gibt aber die sind
sehr klein und deswegen bin ich ganz
klar für mich zu dem schluss gekommen
ich bin schon als proband richtig dabei
weil ich dafür werben möchte dass diese
neue impfstoff technologie auch
anerkannt wird ist in tübingen erfunden
und entwickelt worden und im august als
ich mich impfen ließ da war noch nicht
so ganz sicher ob die so erfolgreich
sein wird dass es mal so weit kommt dass
der konventionelle astra zeneca in den
stoff in verruf ist und da moderne
impfstoffen bei on tape oder cubic dass
der als goldstandard gilt das habe ich
damals noch nicht vermutet freue mich
allerdings dass das so gut funktioniert
weil es ja auch die möglichkeit bietet
sehr schnell innerhalb von vier wochen
dann auch auf neue mutanten zu reagieren
und neue
impfstoffe zur verfügung zu stellen ich
glaube uns ein problem ist das
sicherheitsdenken in deutschland es
zeigt sich hier wieder ganz extrem dass
wir zu viel auf sicherheit setzen in der
pandemie ist schnelligkeit vor
gründlichkeit also umgekehrt wie sonst
das deutsche sprichwort sagt
entscheidend und wir sollten jetzt auch
den astra zeneca für über 65-jährige zu
lassen die briten haben es mit
hunderttausenden getestet wir brauchen
die priorisierung nicht zu ändern wir
müssen ihnen den alten geben wo das
risiko sitzt es wäre jetzt die richtige
maßnahmen und zwar sofort
gut dass wir das von ihnen auch noch
höheren frau oberbeck der russische und
der chinesische impfstoff auch so ein
interessantes thema die bemühen sich
jetzt um eine zulassung der emea würden
sie sagen auch das sollten wir unbedingt
mit auf den zettel nehmen und sagen
natürlich wenn diese impfstoffe
zugelassen und geprüfte geprüft und
zugelassen sind die chinesen und die
russen werden ihr volk nicht vergiften
wollen über den chinesischen impfstoff
weiß ich zu wenig den russischen für
dich definitiv prüfen lassen und jeder
im stoff der als sicher befunden wird
von der emea sollte in deutschland fünf
werden weil wir wollen eine schnelle
durch impfungen der bevölkerung die
natürlich sicher sein soll
aber wie gesagt nicht dass testen wird
die pandemie beenden sondern eben eine
immunisierung und alles was hilft
natürlich ja herr lauterbach johnson &
johnson steht noch der tür muss man
sagen das ist ein impfstoff der
tatsächlich ganz schnell auch etwas an
der zahl der impfungen ändern könnte
weil er braucht keine tief kühlschränke
und er muss nur einmal geimpft werden
ist das der game changer und wird es
auch in deutschland das game changer
oder wenn wir wieder von dem
organisatorischen problem stehen wir
brauchen kann geben ist zunächst einmal
das ist auch ein sehr guter impfstoff
das gar keine frage und bei diesem
impfstoff hat man auch schon erfahrungen
wir gegen die südafrikaner mutation wird
und von dort wo da hatte sich auch sehr
gut erwiesen
somit ein sehr guter zusätzlicher im
sport einfach kein game changer sondern
wir haben die kontingente und es darf
übrigens nicht der eindruck entstehen
als wenn das hauptproblem wäre wir
hätten genug impfstoff aber lotte
wollen sich nicht schnell genug impfen
lassen das hauptproblem ist nach wie vor
dass wir viel zu wenig impfstoff haben
auch das astra problem was wir jetzt
gerade viele leute hätte gerne eine
impfung ja natürlich und wenn du wie ich
stimme ihnen ja völlig zu wenn wir jetzt
die risikogruppen mit dem master
impfstoff helfen würden was ja medizin
ich ohne wenn und aber richtig wäre
die menschen wollen den impfstoff die
menschen wollen impfstoff das also wir
hatten viel mehr und weniger als dem
stoff somit das problem werden da stimme
ich ja nicht so dass wären wir jetzt
lösen
da darf man nicht jeden tag darüber
reden daran wird gearbeitet es wäre noch
eine andere also veränderungen unbedingt
notwendig weil wir haben jetzt die
entscheidenden wochen wir sehen das ufer
der impfung schon für die hochrisiko
leute wir sind aber nicht schnell genug
mit dem impfen und also wir laufen in
die dritte welle hinein
daher so kommt es sehr darauf an dass
wir auch so viel wie wir können die
erste impfung schon leben war die erste
impfung ist der entscheidende
also schritt um den tod oder schwerster
krankheit zu verhindern bei denjenigen
die risikofaktoren haben
und da haben sie ein papier erarbeitet
herr lauterbach der das sogar vorschlägt
gerade bei erster weniger jetzt die
erste unbedingt und dann den zeitraum
bis die zweite kommt wieder schieben
bei biotech und also mit das papier habe
ich zusammen modellierung mit brockmann
gemacht und michael herrmann und ein
physiker ben meyer
das ist aber das papier zeigt einfach in
diese dritte welle pragmatische
reingingen und würden die impfdosen
etwas auseinander ziehen aber noch
innerhalb dessen was die zulassung
erlaubt dann würden wir zwischen also im
günstigsten fall 14.000 menschen im
nicht ganz so günstigen fall 8000
menschen das leben retten einfach nur
durch ein anderes thema und das ist auch
eine pragmatische lösung diese innerhalb
der zulassung und das sollten wir machen
zusätzlich genau was sie vorgeschlagen
haben wird dass wir die priorisierung
nicht ändern aber öffnen die drei
gruppen wollten unter 65-jährigen öffnen
für den astra impfstoff dann gewinnen
wir sehr viel geschwindigkeit und das
zu helfen